[Music]
all right all right we're building it
back up
slowly bit by bit
wait now i just take
and i played a horrible in response
i think i can castle
man i'm listening some chances here
and i think i can just take
just as long as i don't blunderfucking
man
how does he do that
okay at least we got a pretty clearly
defined position
wait how did he take so quickly he
pre-moved queen b2 somehow
i already pre-moved queen b2 and thera
thank you into hero
i don't understand how you're able to
execute that move so quickly
it's like it took him a millisecond to
get the queen from that side to the
other
that's what i talk about whoa oh that's
a freaking no it's not here here
1968 back to d6 and see oh a1
c3ba here it takes before is defended
oh it was a brilliant game and it's mate
made on the back rank
what's up penguin and we got we're
graced by
the two i'm playing and then the chat is
the best cyber boat player in the world
andrew tang
welcome andrew
horrible yeah this is already lost with
alireza you cannot get a pawn down
position like this
okay let's try to break up his pawns and
he's got going d5
of course
well there's a knight there's always
going to be some chances
god ridiculously good play
i think i could have done there
can i go here no he sees it instantly
mm-hmm
this is bad for white
man i'm not stopping him from taking all
my buns
unbelievable
just unbelievable
i'm going to win but still that was to
come back from that position is crazy
these days
okay i'm not too worried about this i'm
worried about the pawn yeah
great chances somehow i gotta go at five
maybe
yeah but i don't really have anything
here
oh watch right now
f4 would have won a piece and
jesus
all right got him that was a big win
and now i'm playing poorly i've done
this against sandra a million times
these kinds of positions are very hard
to play in 30 sec
thank you 100 bits really appreciate the
support guys
subs thank you everybody
oh my god the queen is saying stupid
and now i'm watched it and now i'm worse
he has no moves just paralyzed though
thank you another 100 bits
let's hype it up
it's going to go bishop b6 i was about
to say he's going to go bishop b6 and he
did
he just gifted me a game there
i'm happy if he wants to spot me some
games
she thinks okay 100 bits you're gonna
get some fibonacci action here
okay this is i might as well well this
is not resignable but it is basically
yeah these positions are just oh yeah
yeah he wins
what am i doing
now i gifted him a game
well there's some life here
yeah i let him finish a development
and it's over
wait i can take here maybe
not yet over still probably lost
okay not anymore he just busted up that
one i mean that was just winning
completely
out of the opening out of the gates
for this this is like magnus duboff
we need to get our king the hell out of
there
it's gonna flag and another one is in
the can
thank you drill at the office appreciate
your sub
oh yeah
oh my god only alireza has bishop c5 in
that position
gonna give me some check
that was great pre-moving there at the
end by me
she's gonna go bishop queen take she's i
mean i'm sensing
you might do something dirty
holy smokes charlotte chess center
that's a big boy doughnut with 10 subs
what's we call and he just that's what
we call big boy sub
gift thank you sir
coach peter gifting up the subs
that's what we're talking about
get the hype going boys all right
should have taken that
yeah i mean i was trying there but
hard
wow that was a safe
thank you pj pj gifting us up there we
go
that's awesome thank you pj
yeah we need to avoid i need to probably
go 1v4 or something because this
structure is kind of killing me
not good in the structure i think
oh and as i say i blundered the bishop
forgot to take on f6 first
accident
we need to do something about that
structure
this is lost
i think he's playing like a computer not
me
probably will play 100 games i don't
know
come on e5 is so simple missing this
garbage
oh my god i should have taken this queen
i was just i why did i pre-move that
that was so stupid that was a dumb primo
such a dumb pringles
uh
i flagged him though so we curb the
bleeding there
okay
okay three piece i'm gonna go bishop d8
that would be another resume
best thank you elias
yeah i should have oh my god you just
hit screen h5
okay i have some compensation not
anymore
why would i do that
56 are you kidding me that's a
ridiculous move
all right
that was nice big time save right there
it's a free night and that's our resigns
and there we go
now we're talking ladies and gentlemen
this is actually theory when that's not
theory
not supposed to give up knight like this
e5 here winning peace
okay now we take here here here
take attack
here here
here here
he will probably take and take but okay
then i think i'm winning
probably but okay thank you guys
gifting to us
all right
it's an interesting line i think
hmm why would i do that
okay we gotta run from one side to the
other
run this is okay
oh my lands i flacked him there how did
how did i do that
how did i just do that
oh damn i got checkmated there basically
why do i go for these openings
yeah this is lost okay fair enough
that was just like i just gifted him
that game
now this is a bad position
gotta change things up a little bit here
i knew it's
okay this is fine
everybody's going to go a5
i don't think b3 works
oh my god i shouldn't have primed that
horrible shouldn't have promoted that
now i'm starting to blunder everything
absolutely everything
of course the prim of knight g5
seriously
we're going to go to games let's see if
i can avoid losing the next 13 games
i'm playing like this and of course i've
won it again
unbelievable
so accurate it's crazy
it's just crazy
god
yeah i have to win one against anything
this is a good chance see if i can score
all right we got him big game big game
big game again now we gotta win like 800
and we'll be good
now i'm lost right out of the opening
oh no no no no okay it doesn't matter
over the summer
oh i won that holy smokes that was close
let's see if i can string together two
in a row
nope all right it already doesn't seem
that way
how does he never make premium mistakes
ever
nope can't win two in a row
that's another horrific move
again it doesn't
oh my god
losing everything now
run run run run
big win hey gwen
stem the bleeding okay that's 50. got 18
more to go
see if i can get at least 50 percent
should have activated this a long time
ago
of course i have one second always
just have only one second
so
oh my god oh my god
which is good
i'm going to win the 100 game match but
by how much is the question
and will i have a decent rating at the
end of it
he's hard to take down it is oh my god
he is so hard to take down
oh my god barely barely i
barely won that one
but i didn't that's what counts
okay if he wants this he's going to take
b2
which i just offered up for no reason
i want it back though
i'm happy with my king safety
okay i have a bunch of pawns now
how do i defend this not like that but
it's okay
at least i get active pieces
oh that's me that's a sexy mate
i did not expect that to be
okay we got a sack here
oh and look at that move
rock him cowboy look at that move
queen h3 knight f2 is mate
all right now we're talking
okay we're playing to a hundred games i
hope that's fair i hope that's okay
reza i have to go after that
thank you chess kid appreciate the raid
welcome guys playing
thirty-second chess with all your as a
ferruccia
basically the best 32nd player on the
planet
it's gonna go bishop f1 yeah
another one in the can
300 bits thank you
what was that move
um at least now i can defend the pawn
though
okay can i go here
okay okay he's gonna go bishop e5 and
blast me to death
so we gotta create some counter play
here's rookie five but now i go here
check it's close
um oh i blended the queen
i mean there's nothing i can do about it
yeah it's over
i mean i tried my best there but he's
just a
master at that stuff
no premium mistakes ever
knights are generally good in 30 second
chess
but he only gets doesn't get much
unbelievable i won that okay
home stretch guys can we do well in the
home stretch
no no no no no no no no no okay i did
not expect i thought a knight v6 is the
only move
it's okay no my god
dirty uh well i didn't wasn't paying
attention what he was doing
all right
so dirty
not that i don't do the same thing i do
it's not over though
there's some game left i've learned a
night which she doesn't take
just gotta stop him yeah okay that's a
good move
okay
drop well i drew down a piece which is
good
this is equal i think
no no no no no no no no no no no how
could i blunder a rook there
i even saw it as i was putting it there
that was done
stupid game
okay that's a free pawn
inexcusable blender okay let's go here
yeah i don't like this at all i don't
like having two pieces in the 30-second
game
what i do like is trapping rooks though
i do like trapping ropes that that i do
like
no no no no you're you ain't doing
nothing larissa not this time
i can
oh it's over 104 oh we played over 100
okay i think that's probably enough then
yeah but i have a lesson i need to go
sorry guys i need to go
okay we're gonna we're gonna declare our
last five
the last five starting now
oh my god come on why would i take if i
would remove the next move like an idiot
oh come on
okay we need to go for rectify the pawns
all right four
[Music]
okay here's the window
oh three
i'm up a piece but i'm not even better
two
no oh my god oh my god what am i doing
what am i doing
right
one last one here we go
this is not going to be a good one is it
good games good games early rosa that
was a good match it was a great match
i gotta run guys i'm i'm really tired
and i
have a lesson i gotta prepare for i got
four lessons actually so
i'm sorry but i'm i'm all done for today
oh my god that was a crazy match um
i hope you guys enjoyed it
good game stella reza it's an honor
truly